hey everyone this is sarah with
registered nurse RN comm and today i'm
going to show you how to prep for a
12-lead EKG here we have Miss Smith our
mannequin and I'm going to show you how
to place your leads on how to prep the
skin and show you how you get one so
first what we're going to do is we going
to get our supplies you'll need to get
some electrode stickers you'll need 10
or 12 lead you'll need to get some
exfoliation paper this just roughs up
the top layer of the skin so you get a
really good connection with the EKG
stickers and you'll need some alcohol
prep to clean the oils off the skin so
here we go what you're gonna do first is
you've got to expose the chest to always
warn your patient about that and with
mental patients who are very carry
you'll need to trim the hairs okay a lot
of men have a lot of hair in this region
so always trim those I've got patients
who I've had a Reap rep for an EKG and
the person before me had just through
the sticker over the hair and I had to
take the sticker off and it pulled their
hair and it's very uncomfortable for
them and we could have saved the patient
by just simply trimming the hair so if
you have a hairy chest please trim that
before you even begin next and what
you'll want to do is prep the skin first
we're going to place our arm leads and
our leg leads before you do this some
people like to place the arm leads on
the arms and the legs on the legs but
since this patient is laying in the bed
we're just going to simply use these
landmarks that I'm going to show you so
what we'll do is we'll take your
exfoliation paper and just gently rough
up the top layer of the skin we're gonna
go below the clavicle the brunt of the
bony prominence just right there and
just clean that area we're gonna go over
here on the other the left below the
clavicle and we're just going to clean
that and then we're gonna go down on the
upper quadrant of the abdomen and
because she's a little dissected right
there we're just gonna go
in this area right there just clean
that's your left lower your right lower
lead and your left leg lead
next take your alcohol prep and clean
the area very well to remove it any oils
off the skin because people like to wear
lotions and if they haven't had a bath
in a while there's a lot of oil on the
skin and it'll prevent you from getting
a good connection then we're going to
take our lead sticker there is usually a
little piece of paper on the back of it
so take that off and you're gonna feel
where the bony prominences up the
clavicle you're gonna go just right
below that right there you're gonna
press firmly make sure you get all the
bubbles out and everything and it's on
the skin very well take your other lead
and you're gonna go below the other
clavicle on the left side and watch out
for any defibrillators or pacemakers or
sub-q ports if you do see those go
around those okay never place the
sticker on those devices then we're
going to go with our right lower leg
lead here we go and now our left leg
lead right there okay now we have our
limb leads on we're gonna do v1 through
v6 leads to do v1 this is where you do
your pull your um landmarks you're going
to find the right of the sternum which
will be right here and you're gonna go
to the fourth intercostal space of the
ribs so find your fourth intercostal
space about right there and we're to the
right of the sternum and that is where
we're going to prep with our exfoliation
paper and our alcohol and then we're
going to put our lead on
and we're going to go to v2 it's going
to be on the left side of the sternum at
the fourth intercostal space so it
should be horizontally matching up with
v1 just on the other side of the sternum
can you'll prep and he'll clean and then
you'll place your lead okay now we're
going to we're not going to do v3 yet
we're going to skip to v4 to do before
we're going to go mid curriculum mid
clavicular mid clavicular and you're
gonna go to fifth intercostal space now
on women because they have breasts
you're gonna have to go a little bit
under the breast because you can't just
stick a sticker right there on the
breast tissue and it'll mess up your EKG
so you're gonna go a little bit below
which will be about right there and
before you can always prep because I'm
teaching you guys you can always prep
the skin of course before you place the
EKG stickers so you don't have to do it
individually okay so that's v4 we have
v1 v2 v4 now we're going to go to b3 and
the three is usually just in between v1
and v2 so we're just going to go about
right there
so B 1 B 2 B 3 B 4 and we are going to
skip to b6 this is how you find that
you're gonna go mid-axillary underneath
the armpit and you're going to go down
to the fifth intercostal intercostal
space which should be horizontally lined
up with v4 so we're gonna be about right
there it's mid axillary which is under
the armpit
and it should line up with v4
I'm gonna go about right there and then
we're gonna go to V 5 and V 5 is right
in between B 4 and B 6 so it'll be right
here
so there is your 12 lead EKG set up when
we go over them you have the right arm
lead you have the left arm lead you have
the right leg lead the left leg lead v1
v2 v3 v4 v5 and v6 and then your patient
is ready to be hooked up for an EKG now
if you are doing a two limitary box and
normally they have five leads on for
that that's the little box that they
wear in their room so telemetry can
monitor them normally how that set up
you have your limb leads on and you have
a chest lead on it's really I like to do
v2 or v1 so we'll just keep v1 on just
take other stickers off b2 b3 b4 b5 and
b6 so that's what that would look like
if you were just doing a basic to limit
Reeboks you would have your arm leads
and your leg leads and b1 so that's how
that's set up so I hope that helps you I
remember when I Rob is a student and it
really took me some time to learn how to
prep it since I work in a stress live I
do it day in and day out so I can do it
in my sleep so I hope this video helped
new nurses or nursing students out there
and if you liked this video please share
it with your friends and be sure to
visit my website registered nurse RN
comm for help in nursing school and
thank you so much for watching